foreign
[Music]
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
I got Chuck nice with me Chuck hey Neil
yeah we got a cosmic queries yes one
that's backed by popular demand one of
one of the most uh popular oh yes we had
my friend and colleague Brian Green
theoretical physicist professor of
physics and math at Columbia University
author of The Very best-selling the
elegant Universe followed by the fabric
of the cosmos followed by the hidden
reality my boys into all kinds of freaky
Cosmic stuff and we got him back for
more by popular demand Brian Green
welcome back to start talk thank you
good to see you guys yeah yeah for those
who are watching this on video I think
that's a black hole behind your head it
is full wall sizes just like that that's
did you emerge from that black hole
foreign
we can't have that
but all of your knowledge would still be
intact or is that that that's
information that's information very good
point yeah subtle point I don't know how
many of your audience just got the
subtlety of Chuck's comment which is
crazy I gave him a little diploma
recently I know for how much he's
learned of physics I created just a
little sort of Stark talking and diploma
well because he's yeah oh yeah yeah I
love it let me tell you something it's
it's the it's the reason I do this job
but damn sure ain't for the money
so speaking speaking of money I just
wanted so Brian why you are you have two
professorships was one not enough
professor of physics and professor of
math yeah each department doesn't know
about the other which is
drawing two paychecks that's so funny
okay Star Talk fans don't tell anybody
exactly we meet every day at a very
small Cafe
me in the math department
it reminds me uh of our colleague uh
Sean Carroll who moved from Caltech to
the Johns Hopkins University he has a
dual appointment there in physics and in
philosophy yeah yes yeah so they're
feeding his his interest by those two
affiliations so I guess that's what's
happening with you right
to some extent yes you know I started
out as a math kid and then became a
physics nerd so you know it goes way
back for me in fact you know what
I when I was in junior high school went
to the math department of Colombia and
that's where I first really learned
advancement I just knocked on people's
doors and say teach me stuff and one
graduate student took me off
wow wow you and Neil have something in
common who see kids you better learn
something okay you these people at
universities I don't care if it's Carl
Sagan or the math department at Columbia
they have time on their hands
I'm just saying if they see someone
young and ambitious you can't you can't
not you can't turn that away no no they
can't turn that over I can't turn that
away
not given the culture we've cultivated
here as it just as a nation that values
achievement and and Excellence or at
least most people do I think okay some
people yeah I was gonna say I was gonna
say we are two Nations
exactly so Brian I remembered did you
tell this to me on the air or was it
offline that you were not interested in
a book unless there are equations on the
pages yeah we did I think talk about
that once when I was in college I would
go to the bookstore to look at the
assigned text for a science class and if
there were a lot of words my heart would
sink if it was chock full of equations I
was like okay because you know words can
be ambiguous but the equations are so
precise that that certainly at that time
was what I was drawn to more fully okay
so Brian what are you saying is so that
none of us misunderstand you you should
only speak in equations
perhaps I should I should add I've
matured I've matured since those Early
College days oh okay you're clicking on
some vocabulary human being has become
more important to me I'm just trying to
figure out what book is sitting in
Brian's bathroom right now that's
something
I remembered my freshman year because I
go way back I predate you Brian I I was
taking a computer class back before
computers had their own Department yeah
because it was not yet enough of a thing
to justify an entire academic commitment
by a university but anyhow I was
becoming very fluent in Fortran and then
I had my first dream in Fortran and I
said oh okay I guess I've crossed over
I have not had one of those but I have
had my first lucid dreams have you had
any those oh these are the kind of
people where they where they meet Aliens
and things right that's where all his
mind wasn't mine was a dream yeah I
think the conventional definition is
when in the dream you become fully aware
that you're dreaming yeah oh you realize
that I was thinking no okay that's
different yeah
so okay
yeah it's a very core experience yeah
the first time I said I know I'm
Dreaming because the architecture of the
building was different from what I knew
it to be I said this must be a dream I'm
going to prove it by waking myself up
and I shook myself in the dream and I
woke up in real life wow so the
architecture of the building is what
gave it away that's interesting
absolutely so you want to know here's
the thing I had a lucid dream where I
was on stage and I was doing material
I've never done before I was literally
writing material in my dream and here's
when it when it dawned on me that it was
dream I was bombing and I was like I
cannot believe I embalming and then it
occurred to me wait a minute this isn't
real and I'm in the dream and I was like
I'm waking up
and then I woke up going Jesus Christ
you have a dream and you make yourself
bomb in your own dream like you could
have had a dream where you were at
Madison Square Garden but instead you're
at the same Comedy Club you always work
at and you're failing
usual anxiety anxiety driven dreams but
that's what that is that's an anxiety is
a driven dream yeah well Chuck we got
questions lined up for Brian yes from a
patreon members five dollars a month
gives you access to the genius of Brian
Greene well listen and that's a deal
you're not getting anywhere man you
ain't getting anything like that I have
to like you know calibrate the answers
to reach that level
as far as zero audience no no the idea
is it's a bargain Brian you're not
you're not supposed to give them the
actual value
with some value-added service yeah it's
the entry level that we people have
access there you go there you go what do
you have let's go to Colin Brum and
Colin says
um does quantum mechanics prevent an
infinitely small Singularity inside of a
black hole I thought nothing could be
smaller oh check it out then a plank
link yeah oh so so if we're infinitely
small
you know how how do we violate that
precept yeah Brian you got one with a
black hole above his head
wait let me let me preface that I think
didn't Einstein or or was it Hawking I
think Einstein say there's got to be
something to prevent The Singularity
because that's just not physically you
know God is dividing by zero there so
there's got to be something to prevent
it we just haven't discovered it yet so
where does all that absolutely right in
1939 Einstein wrote a paper where he
basically tried to prove that the
mathematics that suggested a singularity
at the center of a black hole could
never be realized in the real world in a
real world situation
and just to be clear Singularity is
infinitely small infinitely different
I'd like to rephrase it because yes
that's the language that people often
use but to me Singularity really means
any place where our mathematics can't
give us insight to what's going on any
play through the mathematics breaks down
so that's an important point because to
the questioner question
[Laughter]
is because if you take the mathematics
too seriously and you push it into
infinitely small or infinitely dense
then you do run into the kind of
questions that the questioner asks like
doesn't that conflict with the statement
that you can't really go smaller than
the plank length and those are just two
different perspectives one is going to
take the math and just push it
regardless of how far it's going to take
you the other says let's really evaluate
step by step whether this math is
actually applicable
and so this this is the more sensible
perspective
okay so you're saying it's a
mathematical Singularity not a physical
Singularity that's the best that we can
say today now we need to go further okay
it's not enough so now pop out it's yeah
it sounds to me like it's term the terms
that we use we're we don't have the
adequate language to actually describe
because when you say infinite one thing
comes to mind okay but the fact is that
it's really not infinite smoke not I I
but but here's again the point since we
can't actually do the experiment we have
to rely on equations the equation just
take us so far because the equations are
beautiful they not only give you Insight
they also tell you we can't give you
insight into that domain we're not
powerful enough we're not refined enough
and the equations clearly tell us that
goings more than the plank sides are
higher than the plank density is beyond
the reach of today's equations remind
everybody about a plank links so a plank
length is a very specific number it's
about 10 to the minus 33 centimeters
it's incredibly small
and you might say where in the world
does that length come from well it comes
from combining Newton's gravitational
constant planks constant from quantum
mechanics in the speed of light if you
put those together in the right way a
length popped out and that length is the
plank length 10 to the minus 33
centimeters and its importance is the
equations pretty Clearly say don't push
us smaller than the plank length because
we're not applicable in that Dome and
people who talk about infinitely small
are disregarding that and saying well
let's just keep on going and see where
the math takes us and it takes you to a
crazy Place infinitely small infinitely
dense Singularity we need to fill in
smaller than the plank plank or whatever
new idea for length comes into play in
order to have a complete theory of the
world we don't have that yet so we
sensibly should stop at the plank length
because that's where the math ends its
applicability okay so so what you're
saying is
that since the mathematics we we create
that
represent a physical idea
um what you're saying is that
mathematics which is let's say general
relativity
um admits that there's a point Beyond
which general relativity does not apply
yeah especially when you put general
relativity and quantum mechanics into a
combined Theory so General activity
alone doesn't have the plank plank in it
because as I mentioned you need Planck's
constant from quantum mechanics
mechanics doesn't have to plank oh yes
on its own either because you need
Newton's constant from Newtonian gravity
or from the general theory of relativity
that both make use of that number so
it's only when you try to have a more
complete description that you have all
of these ingredients and when they come
together we are told from the math hey
you've got to start thinking differently
when you get to the plank Lane
like Worlds Collide world's colliding
Jerry World's Fair
it kind of is Right I'd like your your
what did you call it Brian a yeah a
shotgun wedding between yeah quantum
physics and general relativity uh in the
early Universe where the two were uh had
to get to know each other for the first
time in dense and small that you needed
both a theory of gravity and theory of
quantum physics so Brian my my sort of
terrestrial version of that uh I think
of lines of longitude on Earth as
separating time zones 24 or so time
zones that we have but of course as you
move away from the equator towards the
poles these lines of longitudes get
thinner and thinner right there's like
the slices like when you slice an orange
from the top down they get narrow and
narrower and they meet at the pole so
you can ask the question what time is it
at the North Pole
and there is no time it has no mean that
question has no meaning at the North
Pole yeah where all time zones meet yeah
and so that's my my baby example pulls
out a very important point because that
analogy played out historically with
black holes and black hole Singularity
because
you know of course that on planet Earth
there's really no Singularity there are
other ways that you could Define time
zones that wouldn't run into this
particular problem so it's really a
singularity born of human invention
because of the way we set up these lines
people early on with black holes thought
that a certain singularities were real
but they turned out to be the analog of
that coordinate singularities bad
choices of loans lines of longitude if
you will and and that's what happens at
the edge of a black hole the edge of
black hole people thought might be
singular but it turns out that it is not
but way down at the center that's a real
one mathematically speaking if you push
all the way down as we said to
infinitely small size you can't get rid
of that one by a change of lines of
belonging to the change of coordinates
so watch your coordinates system yes
what that is right all right so let's
keep going Chuck thanks Colin I spent a
lot of time on that that was a great
question I mean let's go faster go
William Silverman and Williams says hi
Dr Tyson Dr Green Lord nice from a
photon's perspective does any time pass
as it travels at the speed of light if
no time passes from the photons
perspective as it makes its Journey but
the light years pass from the
perspective of the Observer
was it here's the term
predestined to hit my retina when it
left its source from Bill Silverman at
Lafayette Hill so he's getting
philosophical
my man took the uh took the uh the
physical and and got philosophical which
is yeah that's a weird concept when you
think about it but it makes sense yeah
um you know it's a it's a good question
because when you look at Einstein's
special relativity
you find that the faster something is
going the slower time elapses as You
observe time passing on that moving
object you know so as something goes
closer and closer to the speed of light
and we're watching it time elapse ever
more slowly for it so if you take that
with logical extreme at the speed of
light no time would be elapsing for a
photon now poetically that's true but
when we try to interpret it in here we
make a real error because
uh Falcon doesn't have any Consciousness
it doesn't have any means of reporting
experience those ideas don't really have
any relevance so to say that time
doesn't elapse so that Photon doesn't
age is a very human description of
what's going on and this is a
perspective that we humans could never
have because massive bodies can't ever
travel at the speed of light so there's
a barrier for us to ever really know
what that experience would be like but
there's a second part of the question
which is predestination and I don't
think that has much to do with the
notion of how time elapses at different
speeds it a lot to do with how the
universe evolves and yeah I do think
that the Universe evolves by laws that
do not have an opportunity for humans to
intercede and so is there a kind of
predestination built into physical laws
even with the probabilities of quantum
mechanics yeah I would say yes there is
but wait but let me let me make a
practical example of this so if a photon
leaves the center of the Galaxy okay my
thesis data was on Stars at the center
of the Galaxy all right and I would
always think each night that this Photon
who's been traveling for 35 000 years
and it hits my detector instead of some
someone's buttocks on a beach okay so I
guess I'm giving value to these photons
right or a Mountainside but my question
is
if someone if if I were able to watch it
travel and stick a mirror halfway
through to just to send it off in
another Direction
then the photon on being emitted
didn't know I was going to do that
and so it wasn't going to hit my
detector yeah
so the photon that's emitted and
absorbed in the same instant because it
has no concept of time
could that have been anything else could
that have could that have had a
different fate than the one I gave it no
but I would also say that your act is
putting the Merit was also predetermined
in a similar sense that you're a
collection of particles governed by
physical law and I don't believe that
you have intrinsic control over those
particles because you don't control
Maxwell's equations you don't control
Einstein's equations you don't control
things so you think
as far as I know you know but of course
you know so so yes the events of the
universe play themselves out in a manner
that's dictated by physical law and that
means that human freedom of will that we
ordinarily feel that we have I think is
of a different variety than we
intuitively think you know when I lift
up my hand you know I feel like I've
made the choice to lift it up when I
think about it more fully I truly
believe that it was the laws of physics
that required that to happen and I just
am observing how my particles are moving
all right
that's I'm sure that was disappointing
right about now this is when Chuck pulls
out some weed okay I'm talking about
pull out it's sitting right here
I don't have to pull it out
all right what else you got all right
here we go let's go to Liam Cochran
um and Liam says hey this is Liam from
Rhode Island what is it that string
theory proposes that the fundamental
particles we know quarks glucon gluons
Etc are comprised of a combination of
strings vibrating at different
frequencies rather than just another
type of particle what is the purpose of
the string idea behind an analogy to
help people understand the theory in
more simple terms so why not a particle
that makes up the smallest particles
instead of this idea of a vibration or
string thing that causes it to be more
easily understood right and Brian let me
let me prepend that by asking
are you proposing that everything's made
of strings just so that it's more
elegant now
certainly not the man who wrote the book
The Elegant universe is this a
philosophical motivating force for you
because Kepler had his own
philosophically motivating mathematics
where the planets were platonic solids
and it was beautiful because it was it
was math and it was and are you why do
why what confidence do we have that you
are describing reality and not a reality
you want to be true so that the Universe
becomes elegant so you can sell more
books
we're hip to you you you in the
industrial string complex
so that is a key question not the uh the
selling of the books one but the what is
it one of Aesthetics in in making these
decisions and I would say that we
theorists do use mathematical Aesthetics
at times but in the end of the day it's
observation it's experiment and real
tension in existing understanding that
drives our ideas so we began this
conversation with a questioner asking
about the plank length and this tension
between gravity and quantum mechanics
and I said we need to go further because
just saying that they come to
loggerheads at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters is not enough it's not an
answer it's simply letting you know that
you can't trust anything beyond that
point
string theory is an attempt to fill in
the Gap to try to put general relativity
in quantum mechanics together and at
least on paper and we've known this now
for for many decades it succeeds in
putting general relativity and quantum
mechanics together whereas if it's just
a portfolio of particles you don't get
that benefit well here's the interesting
thing if you said that to me seven or
eight years ago I well maybe 10 years
ago I would have said yes you're
absolutely right
there's a lot of progress that's
happened and now we realize that a lot
of the qualities of string theory have a
dual description a sort of mirror image
version in which point particles do play
a role in that description it's a
description that differs from the way we
describe Point particles in the 70s and
80s in certain very specific and
important ways but we're beginning to
learn that string theory is one language
for describing this unification but
there are other languages and languages
sometimes doing folk Point particles so
it's all kind of coming together in a
beautiful tapestry and we're still
trying to you know figure it all out
wow wow and Brian it's been 50 40 years
so I'm very disappointed
I thought you would have had this song
back in the 90s mind if I actually
addressed that because I know it's like
partly a joke but there are people
who with a straight face really do say
that you guys said you'd wrap it up in
five or seven years what's going on and
I just have to keep educating them that
science is not like you know a company
where you lay out your product
development timeline right you know you
you have goals and as you're going
toward those goals new ideas emerge you
follow those new ideas they take you to
wonderful crazy places and as long as
you're not stuck and we're far from
stuck that's what exploring the unknown
is all about you just don't know yeah
but you know what's what's weird is like
when you put it that way it kind of
sounds like someone is saying to you now
the assignment was figuring out the
entire universe why are you late
why is your paper late what they asked
you to do was figure out the entire
universe and yet here you are saying you
need more time yeah okay so I've I have
said this publicly to Brian on stage uh
so this is this this is not differently
mean sounding than when I first said it
it's the same it's okay I've asked
string theories what what's taking you
so long they say it's a hard problem and
then I said wait wait so I said maybe
you are all just too stupid
that's not a consideration here that we
need a different crop of people to enter
your field well I'd say it somewhat
differently yes we always love them we
always want young students you know who
are vibrant and energetics that I agree
but could it be that the species the
humanities is too stupid
yeah that's a real possibility I mean I
mean there's a lot of evidence to uh to
pack that up I'm just saying
you know as as track records go let me
just come down that I'm I'm in the camp
the two stupid cameras I'm down I'm down
to believe that no but we can even go we
didn't even take it out of our species
right I mean I respect the intelligence
of dogs they do some remarkable things
but they don't do quantum mechanics so
there's a species that has a limit on
how well it can understand the Deep
walls of the universe and so why would
we be any different I think it's a
miracle we're not some limit of
understanding here right of course
that's all we've gotten is that problem
also exacerbated by observation the the
the the the inability to have actually
observed yeah because I mean honestly
that's what we do we observe first and
then so Chuck here's where it goes ready
all right so Brian what particle
accelerator do you need now
that was that was funny
sense of scale so take that plank plate
that we mentioned before okay if you
take the plank length is to an an atom
right as as a tree is to the entire
universe damn so that's how small even
on Atomic scales we're talking about and
so yeah we can't probe there directly we
don't have accelerators to probe that
kind of tiny distance and we use our
mathematics to push as far as we can and
that's a tall order and it is a tough
problem that that analogy you just gave
gave me an entirely New Perspective and
respect for the entire field because my
um answer to that once you said that is
oh to hell with it then
let's let's talk about something else
that's insane man that's insane yeah
that's great but as we saw on the first
question it comes into play at the Deep
center of a black hole or the moment of
the Big Bang so these aren't questions
that are irrelevant they're just pretty
extreme
all right Chuck let's try to do some
some rapid rounds okay hairs these are
so good I mean the questions are so good
the answers are so good question I mean
yeah good question we got good people
yeah people are on point today man
all right let's go with Chris Ryan Bruce
Ryan says hiya gents Bruce Ryan here
from Alexandria Virginia everyone knows
E equals MC squared but how is it the
formula actually used in Practical terms
how is the formula actually used in
occurrence I mean if you want to
determine the energy of an object what
values do you plug into that equation is
the mass of grams or pounds is the speed
of light miles per second or kilometers
per hour or does any of that even matter
thanks yeah so
where to use that formula you don't use
it much of course in everyday life but
if you're looking at a nuclear reactor
and you want to know how much fuel needs
to be put in it gives you an order of
magnitude sense you know of what it will
require if you're trying to understand
the sun and the amount of energy that's
produced by Fusion reactions it gives
you a sense of the scales that are
involved now how to actually use the
formula well the key thing that you
learn in science is you have to use
consistent units so you know kilogram
meters per second is the uh num the the
units that we typically will use and so
if you want to use those for mass and
for the speed of light that's a really
good way of getting an answer out in
joules which is a particular unit for
measuring energy but let me just say one
more thing but just to be clear the
clicker the meters per second would be
the speed of light but then you square
that it'll be kilogram meters squared
seconds two seconds squared there's the
unit of a joule right precisely okay now
I said that you typically don't use it
in everyday life but there's something
misleading there and I had a lot of
arguments with chemists about 10 years
ago about this point they were all wrong
but uh
I bet I know what kind of argument we're
having they were thinking that the
energy in their things had nothing to do
with equals mc squared yeah for instance
yeah you know an example that is if you
take a flashlight you turn it on and you
put it on an incredibly sensitive scale
the reading on the scale will go down
over time because energy is going out to
the beam of light and that energy has a
mass equivalent and that mass equivalent
will register on an incredibly sensitive
scale and yeah I've had the same or I've
had the same debates with them
interesting I said it's only nuclear if
it's not clear it has not rolled well
that doesn't make any sense we don't
even have to go to the flashlight in an
incredibly uh um a sensitive scale set
something on fire okay there you go I
mean seriously wait wait wait wait wait
all right so a chemist rebuttal might be
Brian that they have exothermic and
endothermic reactions are you saying
equals mc squared is coming and going in
each of those reactions equal them to
squared is at work all the time
for instance in this simplest example
take a pot of water and turn on the gas
right
as the pot of water gets hotter if you
were on a sensitive scale it would
register a bigger number a small bigger
a small change but a bigger number
because energy is going in and if energy
is going in then the overall mass of
this entity called the pot in the water
is increasing it's always at work so I
did this calculation so I drive an
electric car and so I wanted to ask
myself how much more does the car weigh
on a full charge good
right right and so I ran some numbers on
that some back of the envelope numbers
and it was so small I was going to Tweet
it hey look what I found it was like no
I'm not tweeting this it was like a
thousandth of an ounce or something
ridiculously small but it's an important
point because so many students obviously
some in the field conflate equals mc
squared only with nuclear processes and
it's not it's a physicist it's a physics
thing yeah in fact there's one chemist
came back to me after a year of arguing
and said this has been a year of
soul-searching I now realize that you're
right and I didn't really understand so
much of what I thought I understood
which it was sort of an honest response
yeah yeah and physics there's no real
understanding of chemistry without
physics and there's no real
understanding of biology without
chemistry so Brian is justifiably cocky
in that role
we all know that chemists are dicks
come on come on let's just be real here
that's just common knowledge
[Music]
all right keep going what else do you
have here we go that was not lightning
around speed by the way but guess what I
keep slowing you down I'm sorry it does
make a difference we keep getting in the
areas that we otherwise would never get
into on this show which is fantastic and
we can just have Brian back again people
okay you know it's a real simple thing
he's got he's got agendas in his own
life no I know he's got his a life but
you know I'm selfish so what can we do
here we go this is a surge surge says hi
my question is regarding the subatomic
world if we could scale up an atom what
would it look like would it have some
kind of shell if yes what would the
shell consists of the same question
regarding the smallest particles what is
their composition and what is their
appearance if the Quark is this Wireless
particle what do you get if you divide
it into smaller pieces oh man that's
really cool what does the subatomic
world look like man yeah what does it
look like this really challenges our
intuition because our brains and our
eyes evolved for the purpose of survival
and to survive we just need to be able
to see on the scales of everyday life
and so the language I'm not getting
eaten by a lion
so the language that we developed and
the senses that we have are attuned to
the kind of physics that dominates the
scales of everyday life and those
physical principles are not the same
ones that come to the fore so when
you're talking about an atom we like to
use language that resonates if you
imagine we have a an electron cloud it's
a probability Cloud note what does that
mean in terms of visualization
mathematically I know what it means
there are a lot of locations where the
electron might be found but to actually
see it literally I need to bounce some
light off of it when I bounce light off
of it quantum mechanics tells me I have
affected the thing that I'm observing so
I'm not seeing the probability Cloud any
longer I'm simply seeing the electron at
whatever location the photon hit it and
so it's very hard can I add something
there which is spooky I mean that's
spooky it's disturbing when you think of
about it you everything we see
is larger than the wavelength of light
that's reflected off of it
yeah so yeah yeah so if you if you have
things that start becoming smaller and
smaller
than the wavelength of light we use to
detect it with the thing will just
disappear you'll just basically
disappear so so Brian you need light
waves with wavelengths on the scale of
the things in the atom you're looking at
isn't that correct if we're going to see
it that's right and so and those are
those are more energetic than we're used
to and and they have more of an impact
than the kinds of things you know you've
shine a light on a wall the wall doesn't
move right you know we don't feel the
light bouncing off of us but electron
feels the light bouncing off of it and
that interaction affects how it then
subsequently looks and so it's really
hard to give an everyday visualization
that's at all accurate for what things
are like in a realm that we don't
inhabit directly I wish we could
[Music]
um
wow I like it okay I like it all right
here's a lightning round question Travis
knopp says hi doctors Tyson and green
thank you for taking my question I would
like to know if there's a geometric
center of the universe and what what
what might we find there
me
is that is that you you're there you're
there at the center of the universe well
I have to say one of my highest
retweeted tweets ever was a simple
sentence I said because
the universe has no Center
you can't be it
somehow that deeply resonated with like
everybody yeah
um so Brian can't we talk about a center
of the universe
if we include the time coordinate and so
we say that's the direction of the
center of the universe go there and
you'll see it and that direction is back
in time to T equals zero isn't that a
can I say that well you see Center to
most people's minds is a special
location within a larger reality it's
like that you have all these other
points that are somewhat secondary and
then you've got the center which is
primary and that we don't think applies
anywhere or any when so if you even go
back to the Big Bang the conventional
story although there are modifications
of this but the conventional story is
All of space is in this point
it's not as though it's a point in a
pre-existing well right
there's no construct you don't have a
construct yeah there's no construct
which you would find the center even at
the beginning at the beginning
everything was at quote the center right
but then we'd have to rethink how we use
the word Center yeah and then even once
that comes once that's
I want to say explosion but fans once
the expansion takes place it's like what
is the center of a ball where's the
center on a ball or the surface yeah on
the surface that's the key thing because
if you then imagine the center of it
then you're in a sled but on the surface
of a balloon all points are equal and
there is no Central Point right but if
you do point to the center of the ball
that's where the whole ball was at the
beginning and then we're back to the
original issue you can do that at any
point on the ball yeah yeah exactly at
any point so the retort to your Tweet
might be
because the universe doesn't have a
center you
and everyone else occupied the center
there's no location that's more special
than the one that you occupy
that's not as fun yeah
yeah that doesn't make people feel
stupid
makes it feel special nobody wants that
okay okay this is Andrew Coffey Andrew
says hello to the best science
communicators together uh creating
Cosmic vibrations that will radiate
knowledge cultivate curiosity and
enhance our understanding please help me
understand our limits will we ever reach
a point where theoretical physics can no
longer be explored probed or even proved
experimentally maybe we are already
there thanks NDC from Vancouver British
Columbia and he says I truly love your
work excellent
so so Brian we we all know a cocky
physicist a century ago but you know the
turn of the previous Century saying uh
physics is done
there's no more physics to be discovered
just a few decimal places and a few
touch up some constants and we should
take on another field
so are you do you see where do you see
the field right now well there's a huge
amount of progress but I can certainly
Envision that if we don't build new
accelerators and if we were to stop
building powerful space telescopes we
wouldn't have any new data and without
new data I can imagine I don't know 10
20 100 Years of totally abstract
theoretical research might grind to a
halt and it wouldn't be that we'd sort
of reach the end we'd simply reach the
end in that era until we had the
wherewithal to explore more fully there
has to be an interplay between
observation experiment and theorizing
and so yes I I we're far from there now
but can I Envision that if we lose the
will
to put the effort and the resources and
to understanding the microworld and the
macro world with greater Precision could
we reach an end for a while sure
absolutely
Chuck I just have to praise Brian in
this moment because there are many
theorists he's a theorist who hardly
ever mentioned talk about or think about
experimentalists
they're in their own world and and and
who Brian who was it that said uh never
trust an observation unless it's
supported by a good theory I know the
quote I don't know who's that
unfortunately oh yeah somebody said that
that's a you know that's an
theorist talking right but but Brian is
humble and he knows that at the end of
the day uh good observations of the
universe not only will constrain where
he can or should think but can also
extend what what new ideas might uh be
uh come out of that awesome let's flip
in one more we think this is a good last
one to dovetail on that last uh thought
David Lee's says hi this is David
residing in Xiang Mai Thailand uh what
do you think will be the next major
breakthrough or shifting of our
understanding uh with respect to the
universe
yeah I think everybody will have a have
a different answer on this but I think
that in the next who knows next few
decades we're going to have a much more
refined understanding of the Big Bang
the work that's being done in in
understanding quantum mechanics and
gravity and black holes I think
ultimately the lens will be turned fully
on cosmology
and I can Envision that we will have a
different or at least more refined
version of the theories that we
currently have on the table and in the
best of all worlds we'll finally be able
to answer questions that we began with
like what really do we mean by The
Singularity at the Big Bang what really
happened there I think there's a chance
that we'll have progress on questions
like that
do you think there's anything any
understanding we have that we feel good
about that is at risk of being
dismantled by new or better observations
so in other words is there a shift in
the Paradigm as as they would say in the
in the list so two things one I mean you
know inflationary cosmology is the the
most refined version of cosmology I
there are competitors now and who knows
the scales May shift and our view on
that may change the other thing I would
say is quantum mechanics many people are
quite comfortable as fitted it's been
around for 100 years and it works but
there are unresolved questions that many
physicists don't really spend much time
thinking about and I can imagine that in
the coming years those problems and they
are real I assure you there are real
problems May flare up causing us to
rethink the foundations of quantum
theory mmm I like that flare up nice up
in your face
well Brian it's been a delight to have
you back on Star Talk uh I you know I
don't want to assert my preferences on
our audience because they express their
own but this is where my preferences and
their preferences intersected and
overlapped getting you back on them
thank you there's no end of cosmological
queries that we have flown for you the
truth is every time we say that you're
coming on and we put out a call to the
listeners for for queries we get like
six or seven pages of them yeah they
lose their yeah
I always have to do it all good
questions all right and you and your
books are still out there elegant
Universe uh uh give me the other side of
the cosmos hidden reality but the most
recent is until the end of time and my
most favorite so
until the end of time we'll look for
them all right dude thanks
Chuck always good to have you man always
a pleasure all right this has been
Cosmic queries with the one the only
inimitable Brian Greene friend and
colleague professor of physics and math
right up the street here in New York
City at Columbia this is Neil deGrasse
Tyson as always bidding you to keep
looking up
[Music]
foreign